[Musique]
boga accouché sans douleur une utopie
non pas pour le docteur la manne en 1952
à la clinique des bleuets à paris
ce gynécologue entamé une révolution
peut-être ical ou les ducs leur cercle
c'est une méthode d'éducation on leur
apprend à coucher comme ils ont appris à
lire ou à écrire que mais j'apprendrai à
nager à prendre a accouché sans douleur
la promesse est alléchante pour aider
les femmes à y arriver
le docteur lamaze élabore des cours de
préparation inspiré d'une méthode
soviétique au sein de son service
au programme exercices physiques
relaxation et travail de respiration une
part importante de ces mouvements est
assurée par une éducation respiratoires
ceci pour faire place la respiration qui
a été très justement qualifié de
haletante laquelle sera utilisé or dans
la contraction et si la méthode fait
rapidement ses preuves elle est loin de
convaincre toutes les femmes pour
certaines difficiles de transcender la
célèbre phrase biblique sur enfantera
dans la douleur la femme de regard mal
parce que d'abord c'est un rapport un
peu je crois avec la vierge quand un ami
l'a forgé jument
pourtant la méthode lamaze est aussi
utilisé dans les maternités catholiques
celle ci pousse même le pape pie xii à
légiférer sur cette pratique
le souverain pontife tranche en 1956 il
a donné la légion de l'église or ces
phrases que je lis le chrétien convaincu
ne trouve rien dans ses jt philosophique
et sa culture qui l'empêchent de
s'occuper sérieusement en théorie et en
pratique de la méthode psycho profit de
l'accouchement sans douleur se
généralise alors en france et aussi dans
le monde entier
de nombreux sages femmes y sont formés
et les cours de préparation à
l'accouchement sont même remboursé par
la sécurité sociale
dès 1957 donc vous inspirer autre
nouveauté initiée par la méthode lamaze
les pères sont désormais impliqués dans
la grossesse de leur femme ils font même
leur rentrée en salle de naissance
le père quand il eut la joue un rôle
essentiel dans l'accouchement et il a à
parler avec elle à vivre avec elle au
lieu de la laisser abandonnée aux mains
le personnes étranges heures si elle
fait partie des grandes révolutions
obstétricales la méthode la masse
connaît pourtant une perte de vitesse
dès les années 80 à cette époque les
femmes découvrent la péridurale la
garantie d'un accouchement 0 douleur
aujourd'hui cet acte médical est réalisé
dans 82 % des accouchements
[Musique]